a newly released email is adding fuel to
the argument over president Trump's
impeachment the email shows a White
House official directed a freeze in
military aid to Ukraine about 90 minutes
after mr. Trump's phone call to
Ukraine's president that led to the
house and Pietschmann inquiry chip Reid
is traveling with the president who's
spending the holidays at his Resort and
Palm Beach Florida chip what's the White
House saying right now
well good morning well a White House
official tells CBS News that the email
which was released over the weekend had
nothing to do with president Trump's
phone call in which he asked the
Ukrainian president to investigate
political rival Joe Biden but that's not
how Democrats see it this email is
explosive Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer says the July 25th email is
exactly why new witnesses are needed in
a Senate trial a top administration
official one that we requested is saying
stop the aid 91 minutes after Trump
called Zaleski and said keep it
hush-hush what more do you need
in the email White House official
Michael Duffy directed the Defense
Department to hold off on military aid
to Ukraine and that given the sensitive
nature of the request to keep the
information closely held president
Trump's impeachment stems from the
allegation that he held military aid to
Ukraine in order to pressure the country
to investigate his political rival a
White House official told CBS News the
email was just one of several
surrounding Ukraine and that the hold
was in place before the July 25th call
Duffy is one of four officials Democrats
want to hear from in a Senate trial but
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
wants a quick trial with the evidence
presented before they decide on
witnesses well we need to do is to
listen to the arguments have a written
questioning period and then decide
whether we need witnesses or not you
know the house went ahead without
witnesses they didn't pursue any of the
witnesses in court President Trump has
said he welcomes a Senate trial with
witnesses they had nothing there's no
crime there's no nothing
how do you a beat yet no crime House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi has said she will
continue to hold off on sending the
Artur
of impeachment to the Senate until
Republicans convinced her it will be a
fair trial it's the Senate's job to
dispose of impeachment articles once
passed by the house it's not Nancy
Pelosi's job as for the timing of the
impeachment trial it's still up in the
air both houses of Congress are in
recess until early January so that is
the soonest it could begin vlad all
right chip thank you very much
you